cette résidence nous est protégé par ces
mots là d'accord
avec lui
connaissez-vous la
tu es reculé mais reculé
alors cette image à la énormément choqué
est ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas vous
partez du match gilles verdez bien sûr
will rain in my aussi et on est avec
gauthier le web chouchou connaît
tous on est choqué de tous gauthier le
break et avec nos journalistes ses news
merci gauthier déjà bas c'est quel âge
26 à
26 ans j'aime bien côté j'aime beaucoup
gauthier vous étiez devant eric zemmour
lorsqu'il a mis en joue les journalistes
racontez nous la scène question parce
que ça fait énormément parler en fait eh
bien c'était au tout début de sa visite
au salon milipol donc on l'a vu il teste
un sniper qui est utilisé entre autres
par le raid puis lève le sniper et il se
tourne vers la presse en disant ça
rigole plus reculés reculé sur le ton de
la plaisanterie d'accord alors certains
parlent de mise en danger d'autres
d'humour vous concernant vous êtes senti
en danger ou pas du tout et non
absolument pas à aucun moment on savait
très bien que l'armée était déchargée ça
a duré quelques secondes n'ont à aucun
moment je me suis senti en danger ou
menacés absolument pas d'accord vous
auriez été choqués peu de la même
manière si ç'avait été françois hollande
ou jean luc mélenchon ou emmanuel macron
où c'est vraiment parce que c'est eric
zemmour est ce que c'est parce que c'est
eric zemmour qu'on en parle je pense
qu'on en aurait parlé peu importe quelle
politique on était à sa place si ça
n'avait pas été mélenchon alors d'accord
françois hollande au plus il a va plus
au salon de la pizza
je ne prends pas avec indulgence je dis
simplement que j'ai pas eu peur j'ai pas
dit que j'étais indulgent
je dis simplement que j'ai pas eu peur
je relate en fait j'ai pas eu peur
d'accord vous avez été mélenchon suis
pas sûr que j'aurais été me cacher sous
la table non plus non plus beau qu'il a
été la réaction des journalistes parce
qu'ils n'avaient voulez vous allez
combattre
parce que oui mais
pour tous menée pour l'animation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors allez-y maintenant
oui sur les images que personne ne
réagit à ce moment là parce que ça se
passe très rapidement et personne se
sent en danger il ya plein de politiques
qui ont réagi notamment marlène schiappa
je crois que vous avez montré le lot
twitter chappe à eric zemmour on va voir
le tube de marennes chapin voilà visé
des journalistes avec une arme alors
disons reculer n'est pas drôle c'est
horrifiant surtout après avoir dit
sérieusement vouloir réduire le pouvoir
des médias dans une démocratie la
liberté de la presse n'est pas une
blague et ne doit jamais être séparés
vous avez montré
ce moment là qu'on comprend que ça
devienne une polémique savez vous à voir
et c'est ça la grande odyssée une image
forte évidemment ça n'engage forte mais
on se dit pas forcément que ça va
devenir une polémique à ce moment là on
comprend que c'est une polémique doit
tout le monde s'échangent dans la presse
on se montrent ce tweet vous l'avions
suggéré que zemmour qu'est ce qui vous a
dit eh ben il m'a dit qu'elle était une
imbécile et que maintenant je
m'interroge aussi sur ses propos sur
bernard henri lévy qu'il a tenus sur ses
news en le qualifiant de traître et me
répond que maintenant quand on
l'attaquera il tapera trois fois plus
fort oui comme ça
donc il était il est énervé quand même
est ce qu'il pensait que ça allait faire
une telle polémique eric zemmour je
pense pas franchement je pense pas vous
avez passé la journée donc au salon avec
lui il s'est comporté comment vous avez
l'impression de voir un candidat il a
lâché une phrase intéressante si la
[Rires]
différence de prix bas c'est ça oui
disons qu'il a dit je suis dans la
présidentielle avec c'est quasiment un
aveu bah oui voilà donc bien sûr et puis
c'était c'était pas une visite d'un
écrivain c'est la visite d'un homme
politique de gérald darmanin lierre il y
aura d'autres politiques qui vont
défiler avant la fin du salon milipol
donc c'était la visite d'un homme
politique est d'ailleurs son entourage
confie que quelques candidats après le
15 novembre deviendrait ridicule a
raison bien qu'il arrive à la fin d'une
séquence et que donc dans les prochaines
semaines il devrait normalement se
déclarer candidat c'est cette polémique
que ça fait cette histoire vous pensiez
une telle connu sur cette vidéo ouais je
vous dis au moment où ça arrive on voit
une image forte c'est quand déjà quand
il essaye c'est ça c'est le tweet de
marlène schiappa qui est là bas bien sûr
derrière ça je pense que c'est le tweet
de marie jo si on fait un fait politique
eric zemmour il sait que ça va faire du
bien sûr c'est un jour une punchline une
image chance a vous a choqué moi je
trouve ça hyper choquant pourquoi ils
n'arrêtent pas de parler justement des
banlieues surarmés du comportement
racaille et je trouve que c'est
symboliquement une image absolument
désastreuse mais qu'il arrange bien
qu'ils amusent antisystème aujourd'hui
c'est le nôtre du domaine du grand selve
au choc ça
écoutez c'est déjà démocratique c'est
bon ça c'était des 5 c'est bon mais
alors je ne dis jamais pour qui je vote
pour canet aucun candidat membre
essentiel à voter la loi fillon époque
écoutez vous confondez peut-être avec le
mouvement sens commun ce n'est pas la
manière d'un papa papa c'est plus eric
zemmour je l'aimé bien non mais on verra
d'abord il a pas encore il est beau
comme un candidat on ne connaît pas
encore son avance alors qu'elle n'est
pas encore ses propositions symboliques
ou pas mais il ya une chose alors venir
soient d'accord ah oui ben je vais vous
dire la suite du débat c'est que il a
répondu en disant n'a rien de choquant
qu'elle est une imbécile et la marlène
schiappa continue le filet tire le fil
pour en faire une affaire quand même les
conseillers de marine elle de marianne
chappaz se sont permis tout récemment on
te traiter la manif la manif pour tous
deux conglomérats dessous merde marlène
schiappa like le tweet elle nous a aussi
traité de elle nous a aussi quand mon
épouse et moi non mais non mais non
c'est mon image et vous cherchez des
moines enfin comme toujours
c'est bon tu as tellement c'était avec
les conditions je vais vous touchez les
armes et ouais mais c'est mon
l'acrylique ou casser la tête pour moi
il n'y a pas d'exception et moore alors
je rappelle quand même que le pointe une
arme sur personne
on au moins une arme sur personne
deuxièmement ça va quand même dans un
bain écoutez excusez moi oui mais non
mairie alors dans le site moi c'est pas
ça c'est pas votre ce que vous dites
c'est vous
deuxièmement c'est pas innocent si même
pas ouvert d'humour il pointe les
journalistes alors qu'il vient de la
troisième manche je pose une question si
c'était pas zemmour mais un musulman qui
pour
isabelle il avait les abeilles et
isabelle occupe tobin bell la campagne
[ __ ] en anglais il ya encore six mois
d'avancé sur richard fois en soit à
choquer ou non parce qu'on voit bien qui
tient le physique comme ça il le tourne
comme ça il nous a
comme ça ça n'a rien à voir
la santé non et je suis pas choqué il
pointe une arme qui n'est pas chargée
y'a aucun oui bah merci hier au karité
ya rien et le problème c'est qu'à force
d'avoir des gens comme toi qui sont
choqués à chaque fois qu'il fait quelque
chose et on met toutes au même niveau
exact du plus quand on parle du mariage
homosexuel ou là c'est grave tu mets ça
au même niveau qu'un mec qui a pointé
une arme qui n'était pas chargée bon
c'est un peu maladroit c'est pas très
grave il n'a pas menacé la démocratie
avec une arme chargée dans une danse
dans un salon est temps qu'il y ait si
et si si voici ma grand mère avait des
roulettes ce sera un autobus
[Applaudissements]
soap and skin abouti au
sérieux regardez et magnifique
j'adore côté moi si je l'avais reçu un
gel et qui fait même si gentil ce
tintouin très bien j'aime bien c'est un
talon toi mais si quelqu'un lui priorité
s'ils veulent le mayen non mais un moyen
voilà qui fait coacher au c'est sûr j'ai
pas de nouvelles encore mais c'est sûr
alors là il faut que je rectifie tout de
suite parce que sinon je me fais
engueuler mon coeur est pris
n'est pas de ton coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai
en tout cas il que dirait on peut dire
merci à une personne est peu dire
effectivement merci à marlène schiappa
parce que je pense que compte comme
thème dit géraldine à mon avis c'est
absolument pas anodin il l'a fait parce
qu'il savait qu'il pouvait
éventuellement créer une petite séquence
le tweet de marlène crée du coup une
vraie s'est passé au liban c'est une
vraie séquence politique parce que
derrière évidemment que tout le monde va
reprendre les arguments ou de marlène
schiappa en disant ils cherchent à
mettre au pas la presse en europe sous
coups d'humour etc et de l'autre côté on
aura un argumentaire politique en
faisant vous venez me parler de ça mais
je
serai là ça m'emmerde
la lumière ça me choque pas parce que
c'est eric zemmour il fait du reggae
moore c'est à dire de la provocation et
puis au delà de la blague c'est comme
une image qui symbolise la guerre entre
eric zemmour et certains journalistes
feras police mme à 50 ans elle défonce
et ali mezghani gagnez vous essayez ça a
duré trois secondes de monsieur n'est
quand même pas choir est allé
journaliste heures hasard marlène
schiappa paris qui fait le point chaque
famille dans une zone avec les mêmes
qu'avec les homosexuels qui ont des
enfants la bêtise
[Applaudissements]
la berd rester parce que ton ben non
j'ai justement pour les enfants je pense
que c'est absolument fondamental passe
avant tout et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
confondre les armes et les enfants et
que là vous faites une confusion excusez
moi vous êtes indulgents que j'ai dit
non mais les comparaisons n'ont pas lieu
mais pour revenir à ce qu'il a fait ça a
duré trois secondes et c est en fait
marié ne va pas elle en profite et elle
est enchanté de faire du buzz avec ça et
c'est sa grande spécialité vous que ça
peut choquer
[Rires]
mais moi ça ne me choque pas moi ce qui
me choque
d'essence aux 100 mg ont surtout vous ne
fait que renforcer sa force mais les
gens qui votent pour lui franchement il
a fait un truc et maladroit mais y'a
rien 12 mois la droite
plein alors évidemment d'enfants tous
les soirs ça franchement sanaa ça n'a
aucun intérêt son bonbon francheville
masturber n'ai-je pas quoi
tu as donné ton est bien de lui
avec lui j'ai de faire quatre gauthier
oui
j'ai bien fait de venir
[Applaudissements]
mais parce que vous êtes mais non
enfin écoutez c'est pas fini ma question
à tout le monde m'a prévenu avant de
venir tous dit quoi battus fera
attention match de leur mois
[Applaudissements]
les connaissais rien des matches dans
mon frigo la cud ovine chasteté plaît
c'est vrai ou pas voilà voilà voilà
c'est ça c'est ça que j'aime à mon poste
aussi que je voulais arrêter
ben j'ai dit ce que vous m'écoutez pas
ou quoi non non les fonds de fiducies
comme je l'avais demandé puisque
finalement que ce n'était pas ça paraît
utile madame vous avez des enfants 1
est ce que votre enfant est homosexuel
il veut se marier avoir des enfants dans
des telles choses à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moitié donc pour toi c'est une polémique
qui n'avait pas lieu d'être oui oui je
me prononce pas là dessus parce que
c'est une image forte mais à la question
est ce que j'ai eu peur non d'accord le
manager pas été choqué mais j'ai pas eu
peur d'accord je vous laisse débattre du
fait si c'est le chemin de vigne neutre
journaliste je ressentais fait
suffisamment
mais memory exclusivement au feeling de
dire pas ici mais on n'entend que les
journalistes auraient eu peur ça aurait
été choquant c'est donc là pour cet été
- participant à la scène j'ai dit que je
n'ai pas eu peur ben oui mais
impressionné donc là c'est vous êtes
témoin puisque journalistes on se
comprend 4
27% oui maintenant non voilà 27 fois oui
ils sont là